there's a guy who who you know posted a
nasty Meme and you've permanently
removed his ability to speak in the
public there's no redemption in right
according to the
um Theology of cancellation I just want
to point out the Clinton Global
initiatives on Twitter
you know yeah there's a lot of war
criminals and monsters there's you know
terrorist organizations that are on
there openly using the platform without
any kind of problems when Twitter a
couple years ago was looking at of
course right-wing talking points that
they needed to censor and take down so
uh it's crazy because this this is a
very important issue and and we can't
underplay it because yes I mean we got
to celebrate our victories Elon did
incredible things on Banning a lot of
important people that were uh punished
for their political speech but if you're
going to continue the punishment based
on your own kind of made up uh standards
that that's something that doesn't give
me hope that's something that I think a
lot of people should be skeptical of and
I think that's something that a lot of
people should be criticizing him on
because obviously it doesn't stand with
any kind of virtue